uh uh oh thomas massey has entered the
chat of course
of course speaking of alpha cucks
oh my god it just doesn't end with these
[ __ ]
doesn't end and there's such an endless
list of these [ __ ] [ __ ] bags
just doesn't [ __ ] end
then i know that's what this is
i know that's what this is it's from
this tweet
oh my god
over 70 percent of americans who died
with covid
died on medicare and some people want
medicare for all you are such a dumb
[ __ ] you see okay so here's the
thing
here's what thomas massey trying to do
other than being a [ __ ] idiot
okay
they have had no [ __ ] policies
they've been running on no policy no
[ __ ] position other than they want to
be fascist
guns
and trump is our god like that's it
that's it full stop that's all they've
got that's all they've had for a long
[ __ ] time almost six goddamn years
jesus christ they can't even they can't
even they can't even figure out that the
next election is closer than the last
one
like literally the [ __ ] election that
we're about to have is closer to us than
the last one they're still bitching
about still trying to overturn they're
still trying to [ __ ] undo our vote
they still haven't figured that [ __ ]
[ __ ] out
because they have no [ __ ] policy they
have no positions because their ideas
[ __ ] suck
and they know that we know that their
[ __ ] ideas [ __ ] suck
they're [ __ ] horrible that's why they
can't say these [ __ ] this [ __ ] out loud
now here's one thing they they do know
with this medicare for all right they do
know that democrats in the last primary
for the presidential election rejected
medicare for all they rejected it
uh elizabeth warren ran on it bernie
sanders ran on it and biden ran
opposite of it we're not gonna do
medicare for all he said we're not doing
that thing
we're not doing that thing
we're not gonna do that thing right
that's what he said that's what he said
and biden won handily against bernie
sanders
and you know these republicans know they
know that medicare for all
that medicare for all is a wedge issue
in democrats you see that
you see what this [ __ ] is trying
to do
they know what they're doing here
they're trying to drive wedges in
between democrats right they're trying
to get us to fight whether medicare for
all is good or not right that's what
they're trying to do [ __ ] that [ __ ]
we're not gonna have that argument we
shouldn't have that argument and if
you're out there tweeting about that
argument you're you bought in you bought
their [ __ ] bait hook line sinker you
bought it
so if you're pro-democracy don't take
debate here on this [ __ ] stupid thing
we should drive wedges in between them
that's probably what the 100 of
americans um is about because 100 of
americans think tom massey is a [ __ ]
idiot
seventy percent of americans who died
from cover died on
died on medicare
you stupid [ __ ] we were saying that from
the beginning
that we had to protect
older folks and people who are
vulnerable in this country and most of
the older folks and people who are
vulnerable in this country are on
medicare you [ __ ] idiot
by default
dumb [ __ ]
and some people want medicare for all no
most people don't want medicare for all
you know what most people want they
don't want to go [ __ ] broke over a
medical bill
that's how we drive the wedge you see
the messaging there we don't want
medicare for all we just don't want to
go broke over a medical bill
that's it i think most american families
just don't want to have to file
bankruptcy because they got in an
accident
because they can they they got cancer
because they developed a disease over
time
because they had a child that was born
with a disease
they don't want to [ __ ] lose their
way of life and their well-being over an
illness
that is beyond their control
i think that's what most americans want
i don't give a [ __ ] if you're voting for
bernie sanders joe biden or donald trump
most americans would agree that they
want that
thomas massey's a [ __ ] idiot and your
tweet sucks [ __ ] it sucks
it's a horrible [ __ ] tweet delete it
yes i want to [ __ ] tweet that thing
oh let's see what else we got here
oh [ __ ]
helen kennedy oh my god this is
fantastic helen kennedy says many people
who died do so in hospitals ban
hospitals right
100 percent of americans are having a
good laugh at your expense thomas that's
a hundred percent right people [ __ ]
boneheads
just complete [ __ ] boneheads they
don't they don't get it
they won't get it they're not gonna get
it they're not going to
let's see if we can find
um
bill lights says 100 of americans who
died coveted wouldn't have to read this
[ __ ]
i just did and again
if you're not aware what they're trying
to do here what they're trying to do is
they're trying to drive a wedge about
medicare for all they're trying to bait
the the national the national discussion
back into
politics right
they're trying to bait it back in
they're trying to get us to go after
each other on medicare for all they're
trying to get us to argue
not just out here on twitter and in real
life they're trying to get democrats in
congress to argue about this they're
trying to get the media to argue about
this which the media will buy this the
media be be aware be aware if you're out
there turn your cable off for a couple
[ __ ] days
because the media is going to buy this
stupid [ __ ] hook line sinker they're not
gonna say what i'm the [ __ ] gonna say
that this is [ __ ] stupid and it's
bait it's [ __ ] bait and i have the
discussion about medicare for all i
don't give a [ __ ] we already done did
this we had this decession in the
democratic primary the americans decided
this already
they decided it already we did this
decision we did this thing
where we had a primary we'll have
another one in 2024 and possibly 2028
for a democrat
we'll do it again we'll have this
discussion again in a few years but we
already had this discussion we do not
need to have this discussion inside of
our party
or inside the country for that matter
what we the discussion we do need to
have is to make sure people don't go
[ __ ] broke
over a goddamn medical bill
[ __ ] thomas mancy
well
it's a damn shame we already got the
bonehead of the week up because that
[ __ ] would be on there again
now speaking of bonehead of the week go
vote
go vote for the bone end of the week
follow us at tonymichaelspod
on twitter and at tonymichaels and i am
gabe sanchez
there on the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends
that way you can vote for bone end of
the week here's our contestants this
week
brian suave or whatever the [ __ ] this
guy is
um forrest gump i mean representative
kevin mccarthy and then jared kushner
those are our
those are our contestants speaking of mr
mccarthy let's go